(upbeat music)
- Welcome your Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
man, we hate to see you guys fight.
We hate to know that you're
experiencing conflict,
that you're in arguments
with with one another.
Those arguments might be life altering
or ridiculous in nature.
Doesn't matter to us.
All that matters to us
is that it's resolved.
And that's what we pride ourselves on
is the ability to resolve conflict,
to save relationships, save marriages,
by giving you the official-
- I would say restore relationships.
- Yeah and that.
The official answers to these questions.
There is an objective truth
- And we have it, we have it.
- We have it for every single
one of these questions.
Actually, we have not
discussed these beforehand.
We may disagree, but one
of us will win the argument
and if it comes to blows, then so be it.
- Huh.
The prompt we put out there,
follow us on Twitter,
talk to us using #earbiscuits.
You can be shouted out on the show.
Your dirty laundry can be
aired in front of everyone.
And to prove that hey, we're all the same.
I don't know to try to put
a positive spin on that
so people don't get scared that
we're gonna make fun of 'em.
"Got an argument, conflict
or disagreement you can't resolve?
Let us know and we'll handle it
on an upcoming Ear Biscuits."
That was the post and
now this is the show.
Full circle.
It's happening.
- It's like magic.
- Before we get into this,
there's another thing
that Ear Biscuits is
at the hub of besides-
- The hubub.
- Hub of besides-
- Ear Biscuits is the hubbub.
- Resolving conflicts.
And that is any news related
to the window in my shower
has to funnel through Ear Biscuits.
It might then go off into
I don't know a vlog that we make
when we were making those.
- Remember that?
- That was great.
That was a fun one.
- Are you making the window bigger?
- I have an update
on the window.
- Full body.
- Boy, I'm thinking about it.
Yeah as you probably know
the window is in my shower and it's only,
it's from the collarbone to
the top of the head, okay?
- Yeah, it leaves a little to be desired.
- Hmm, thank you.
That's a nice compliment.
- It's one of those things
that when you sell your house
and somebody comes into it,
people are gonna have questions
about the window in the shower.
- The first reaction is gonna be negative.
But then when they buy my house
and every experience they
have with that window
is going to be positive.
I have another positive point
because like I said
I pushed for this window to be installed.
Christie was scratching her head.
The contractor was scratching his head.
Everybody was scratching
all types of stuff,
except for me,
I was scratching the itch
that was the desire to have
a view while taking a shower.
And it goes beyond.
Okay yes, there was a problem
with my neighbor seeing.
I think I've given a little
bit of an update there.
I have video to go along with this.
So I'mma have my phone ready to pull out.
Let's see where do I start?
Course my bathroom's on the second floor
and then the rest,
our master bedroom is on the second floor.
Everything else is on the first floor.
And when I'm looking out the window,
I'm kind of looking over my roof
into the distance.
I was in Lily's room,
so I was downstairs,
I was talking to her and she's got,
her room was like,
she only had this one window
and then because of the
bushes beside the window
it was always so dark in there.
I was like you need a sunroof,
you need a skylight, they call it.
So actually as part of this construction
with the remodel of the house,
we also put a skylight in her room.
- Oh, I didn't know that.
- Yeah, it's a little square,
however big that is.
I don't know, two by two.
It's a small one.
- 18 by 18 maybe.
And I look up there and I'm like,
"Man, your skylight is dirty."
She's like, "I never really look at it."
I was like, well-
- How much sunlight gets in?
Because putting out a
skylight in a bedroom
means that now the sun
comes into her bedroom
when the sun comes up,
which is not a teen thing.
- It has a shade on it.
I'm like you know what,
I'm gonna optimize this.
I'mma get one with a shade,
with a remote.
So yeah, she has her own little shade
and the skylights in our living room,
I also put shades on those
'cause when it gets real
hot, it gets real hot
and you don't want it to get too hot
so you close those shades
in the big part of the room.
She didn't seem to be too phased by it
but it just stuck in my head.
I'm like, my role is to
keep the skylights clean.
I've squeegeed all of
the skylights before.
- From the outside?
- I got to get a ladder.
I got to get my window squeegee.
I got to like make my suds.
I've got to bring another thing of water
that doesn't have sons to rinse it off
because I can't get the
hose all the way up there.
It's a problem.
So when I realized, man,
you're due for a cleaning,
I just kind of logged
it away and I'm like,
you know, maybe six weeks from now
I'll get up there and I'll
squeegee the skylights again
and I'll enjoy it.
But then lo and behold,
the next day I'm in my shower showering
and I just found myself
thinking about the skylight.
Now when I look out my window
I cannot see Lily's skylight.
- Right.
- But if I open my window and look down,
I could see it
if I really tried.
But you have to really try to see it.
So I just want to preface it with
if I'm in my shower
I can't look down into
my daughter's bedroom.
That would just be weird, strange.
- Well, it's also probably a translucent.
- It's clear.
You could see in it.
- Interesting.
- But the angles are such that you can't.
But I didn't think,
hold on, I've got a shower
head here that comes,
it's got this, I've got
the shower head above,
like the rain shower head,
but then I got the one that
I can take off the wall
and like the wand.
I can shower up different places
and under different places and rinse.
My rinse game is tip top man.
- There should be laws
against people like you.
- You should see me rinsing myself.
I should get a video of that.
But it occurred to me, I can spray,
I can wash Lilly's skylight
while I'm in the shower.
- First of all, let me just say doubtful.
I doubt that you're gonna get the pressure
that is required to pull this off
but you're also gonna
freak your daughter out.
- I'm also gonna show you a video
because I knew that's
what you were gonna say.
Here we go.
All right, you know what time it is.
It's time for a shower update.
The window's still there
and there's always
something new to discover.
- [Rhett] Hold on, are you naked in this?
Because there's a reflection on-
- [Link] I'm shirtless.
Fence, so it's harder to see me.
Yeah so the neighbor put a fence.
That's the update there.
Because what I discovered was
right down there is a sun roof,
sun roof, I call it.
- [Rhett] Sun roof (laughing).
- If it gets dirty,
isn't this exciting?
- Not really.
But did you, is Lily home at this point?
- I think she was sleeping, yeah.
Put this thing on.
I could wash my whole roof, see?
- [Rhett] Well not really.
I mean you gotta get-
- [Link] Yeah.
Not enough pressure.
I change it to, oh yeah blast
and bring it out there far enough.
Yes, yes, yes, look.
I can clean the sun roof.
Brilliant, brilliant!
From my shower.
I'm cleaning the sun roof from my shower?
- [Rhett] Did this wake her up?
She had to think, oh, it's raining.
- [Link] She thought I, she was like
wake up, Lily, it's raining.
I'll tell you in a
second when this is over.
- [Rhett] Did it work?
Did it clean it?
- Pretty great.
Yeah, pretty great.
- It did work, it cleaned it, man.
- That's just a testament of how often
it doesn't rain in California
that just a lower pressure shower water
is gonna clean the-
- Yet another reason that
that window in the shower
is perfect.
I went to work before Lily got up
and when I got home, she was like,
"Dad, were you on the roof
washing my skylight this morning?"
And I was like, "No, I was in my shower.
I washed your sun roof from my shower."
- How did that make her feel?
- Not surprised I think
was pretty much it.
She was kinda like yeah that's just-
- Is she the only one who got a skylight?
- She's the only one that needed it.
- Okay.
- And she doesn't have a
window in her shower either.
She's not asking for one.
Don't know what's up.
But I just feel like it's my duty
to keep you filled in on
the continual enjoyment
that I'm having in my shower.
- I thought that your,
I was hoping,
well and I like to believe
that the neighbor did see this happen.
I like to think that
the neighbor has a blog,
like a Blogspot
and it's called "My Neighbor".
- Mystrangeneighbor.blogspot.com.
- And they are,
they both contribute to it.
The husband and the wife contribute to it.
And it hasn't been updated many times.
This is like,
at most every six months,
which is a typical Blogspot cadence.
And the latest entry is like,
"You won't believe what came
out of that window this time."
You know it's like, how
would you explain it?
Because they probably
can't see the skylight.
So they just like see this man,
they just see him like squirting his roof
and like changing the pressure.
And they're like, what is this fool doing?
I'm so glad we put that fence up.
- It was so much easier to wash.
I mean, I would like to have
been able to squeegee it.
So I think what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna get a really,
a long extendable pole
with a squeegee on it
and I'm gonna keep that in the shower.
But you have all the other skylights too
that are getting dirty at
the same rate presumably.
- You're right.
I didn't want to bring that up but yeah.
- You don't sponge it?
I would think you would take
like one of those mitts that
you like was a car with and,
have you done one of these?
I would think you'd be really,
I know you're into cleaning things.
- I got a special squeegee.
And on one side it's
got like the scrubber.
It has a long sponge across it.
Yeah and you scrub it with that
and then you flip it
over and you squeegee it.
- Yeah 'cause that's just
sort of a wash and dry in one.
- Yeah, just like the people here in town
who wash your windshield at a red light.
- That doesn't happen anymore.
- Without you asking.
But yeah that hasn't
happened in a long time.
- No.
- Huh, all right, so that's my update.
Don't worry about it.
I've still got it.
We're still good.
- How's your eyesight?
Well you can test it unofficially
with the Good Mythical
Morning Eye Chart shirt.
Look at this.
I mean people are gonna look at this
and they're gonna try to
figure out what it says
and then you're gonna tell 'em,
"Oh, Good Mythical Morning,
it's a show."
And what does that say on the bottom?
- Ical morning.
- What's it say on the bottom?
- As you can see we can't.
- Oh as you can see we can't.
- Yes.
Nice little slogan.
- I mean it's tough to get a graphic
that is this wide.
To get a number that far over.
- But we had too 'cause that was accurate.
We had to be accurate.
- Usually you don't go
much past the nipple
but these numbers are two
inches outside of my nipple
which is really impressive.
- We cannot be contained by
standard printable areas.
Mythical.com.
- This isn't some print-on-demand thing.
I mean we do that too as well,
but that's not what this is.
- No, this is a we demanded it be printed.
- Right, totally different.
Mythical.com.
- Good work, team.
Abley, Abbey Bigler to help
us settle this argument,
"Is it less gross
to borrow your significant
other's toothbrush
than to borrow a friend's toothbrush?
I say yes.
My boyfriend says no,
they're equally gross.
- Your boyfriend is wrong.
This is not a difficult one by any means.
I mean-
- They're not equally gross,
but they are both very gross.
- They're both gross.
- If I had to choose one person
to brush my teeth with their toothbrush,
I would choose my wife.
- Right.
And I think the answer is simple
because you're regularly,
assuming that you have a healthy marriage,
regularly swapping spit
with your wife, you know?
So you basically have,
I would think there is
a culture of bacteria
that has actually been
influenced both ways
in your mouth and in your partner's mouth
because that's what happens
when you just constantly,
I mean like my wife and I are
just constantly making out.
- Like French kissing?
- Constantly French kissing.
Right when we wake up,
right before I leave,
first thing when I get home,
right before we go to bed.
And it doesn't always lead to sex.
I mean sometimes it's just French kissing.
- Let's be real for a second.
Let's be real for a second, right?
I mean it's not really
detached from foreplay
in my home.
- There's not a lot of
just make out sessions
when you've been married 20 years, yes.
The make-out sessions
usually lead to completion,
a complete mail sorting session.
- Usually?
I would say for me,
I would say almost
exclusively at this point.
- What if you get into an argument though?
Sometimes that'll put a stop to things.
- So then it just counts
as a makeout session.
- Only if something else,
some external factor gets in the way.
But you know what we're saying.
You kiss your partner
and therefore your mouth
is touching their mouth
directly on a regular basis
and so their toothbrush-
- What do you think about scheduled,
let's talk about just
French kissing for a while.
Let's not get back to toothbrush 'cause I-
- Scheduled French kissing?
- Yeah, what do you think about that?
It's kinda like, you know-
- I don't like scheduling anything.
- You schedule things when
they never happen otherwise.
- Well, I mean it happens.
- But it happens and then it stops?
Like we're just having a make-out session.
- Don't say we, just talk
about you and your wife.
- We, I'm referring to me and my wife.
- You and Christie are having
a make-out session, okay.
- And that's it.
I think that's gonna
require some planning,
like some expectation management.
- I think it does happen.
- I think I need to be
biologically ready for that.
- I think it does happen,
but I think I do usually interpret it
or let's just be honest,
I like to believe that it
is contributing to foreplay.
Even if it's like four p.m.
and I know that the mail sorting
is not gonna happen anytime soon,
if there's making out happening
what I'm thinking is, well, here we go.
This is a deposit in the bank.
- Now I'm bringing zero
judgment into this.
This is all curiosity.
Because for me this never happens.
Are you saying that like you and Jessie
might pass each other in the house
and then you'll just start making out?
Has that ever really happened?
There's no way, right?
- Yes.
- What, really?
Like French kissing?
- Well if you're gonna
kiss, do it like the French.
- Christie and I will hug
and we will kiss each other on the mouth.
- I'm not saying it's like a normal thing-
- But we're not gonna go
into like a make-out session.
- Well, okay, when you say session,
how long is a session?
- Forget session, tongue, tongue.
- The tongue will breach, yeah.
- Now I mean like be more specific.
- My tongue will go into her mouth
and her tongue will go into my mouth.
Do you want me to draw you a diagram?
- No, I'm cool with what you've told me.
How often does that happen?
- Not often at all, but I'm saying,
you just said it never happens.
No, it happens.
It has happened.
- It never happens to us unless,
and I'm not saying it's
automatically foreplay,
but you have to be in,
it only happens to us in a zone,
I think that's true, yeah, okay.
- Listen, I don't want to
paint an incorrect picture here
that this is like every
time you turn around
I'm making out with my wife.
And I'm sure that there are
some couples where that happens.
I'll be honest that I
think I kind of represent,
you know a little bit of
a stereotypical husband,
you know, situation, which is like,
if that's happening, I'm
kind of thinking about it
in reference to what it
might lead to, right?
Just be honest with you
that's how I think about it.
- And even if your brain's not
thinking about it that way,
the rest of your body biologically is.
- And so, but there are times
when it would just be a
thing that just happens
and doesn't lead to anything
and that's not what the expectation is
because of where we're at or when,
I mean also things like
being on a date sometimes.
There'd be some making
out that happens on date.
Like where?
- In the car.
- Okay in the car, yes, in privacy.
I'm still picturing like at the-
- Why does this got to be PDA?
- That's what I wanted to clarify
because that's what I was picturing.
I mean not that I was picturing it.
- My wife would be okay with us making out
in like a restaurant because she would,
I would think that she would
think that that was like,
oh, he's not scared to show
his love for me in this place.
But I just, you know, it's
kind of a McGlaughlin thing.
We're a little bit sensitive
to PDA or PDOA as my dad says.
He puts the O.
Public display of affection.
(laughing)
He always does the O.
- PDOA?
- PDOA, no place for PDOA.
- No one's ever said that.
- My dad has said it many times.
So that's what we say whenever we say it
is like PDOA.
- You know what, I hereby resolve
to tongue kiss my wife period.
- Because you don't care about PDOA
and what people think about it.
- PDOA, PDOA.
(laughing)
PDOA, wow.
I thought more highly of your father.
- No, but here's the thing,
it's not, I refuse to believe
because my dad doesn't have
those things that he says
that are like the incorrect
pronunciation of something.
So I choose to just believe
that he actually is correct
and people just drop the over
for illegitimate reasons.
- All right, you want to
go back to toothbrushes?
Here's the thing,
yes, I will tongue kiss my wife
but that doesn't mean I
want to use her toothbrush
because I actually want
her to use her toothbrush
and me to use my toothbrush before that.
Now that's not a requirement.
We don't like,
we don't have to like detox
before we have intimacy-
- But if you're on vacation
and you realize that you
forgot your toothbrush-
- More often than not,
we're gonna brush our teeth
before there's any like makeout.
- Well okay of course, you're married.
But if you're on vacation
and you realize that like
first night you're like,
oh crap, I forgot my toothbrush.
I know exactly where it's sitting
right there on the counter.
What do you do?
- The front desk'll usually give you one.
- 100%.
First of all, I'm not solving
the problem right then.
I'm going to bed.
I'm going to bed without brushing my teeth
because I don't think that
that's that big of a deal.
- I would probably swish or like,
if I wasn't just going to bed,
but if there was gonna be some making out,
and let's just say that's it,
huh, nothing else,
I might use some toothpaste on my finger.
- Okay, that's acceptable for sure.
- Anything to freshen up.
- But if there's not gonna be making out-
- But I would do that before
I use Christie's toothbrush
even in that scenario.
- There's many things that I would do
before I would use Jessie's toothbrush.
And I don't think I've
ever used her toothbrush
'cause I do believe that it is gross
and I do believe that it
is grosser than kissing.
- Because it's a cleaning process.
- But that wasn't the question.
Is it less gross
to borrow your significant
other's toothbrush
then to borrow a friend's toothbrush?
Yes!
- Absolutely, yes,
less gross, but still gross.
I think her boyfriend is saying,
no, they're equally gross.
Okay, they're not.
Abbey, you're right.
But you know what?
Some arguments you just,
you don't need to win.
Is this one of those arguments?
- Well no, I think that she won this one.
- Yeah, we think she won
but I don't know if he's gonna,
if she needs to press it to the point-
- I think there's something
going on that she didn't,
I think there's something
under this question
that she did not reveal,
which is I think that she
either has used his toothbrush
or it's like he forgot his
toothbrush and she was like,
"Just use mine."
And he's like, "No, that's gross."
And then they got into this argument.
So whether or not
you should use your
significant other's toothbrush
is a different question
than the one that was asked here.
We're just answering the
question that was asked
and talking about a lot of other stuff.
- I would not use,
I think that I have used
Christie's toothbrush,
but I think it was an accident,
but then I didn't feel horrible about it.
- Yeah, especially if you
get the water real hot.
- Yeah.
When you're done with your toothbrush,
do you really clean it under
the hot water afterward?
- I really clean it.
I do not really clean
it under the hot water.
- What are you cleaning it with?
- Just the water.
- Oh okay.
I look at it
and make sure that there's
no like white gunk on it.
Well and the cool thing about, and this,
not a sponsor right now,
but the Quip black toothbrush,
the bluetooth one,
is that you can see any
little residue of toothpaste
because it's black.
And so it makes you clean it even better.
- Oh.
- Yeah, let's move on though.
Ashley Sizemore,
"Is it okay to leave
your glass on the counter
with the intention to use it again later
or do you put it in the
dishwasher and get a new glass?
Sincerely, the family who disagrees."
Wow this is really, this is so relevant.
- Yeah, this is tough.
- To my own experience because-
- It hits home.
- I'm of two minds of this
because first of all, my family,
and I'm gonna say mostly my kids,
they use so many cups
and glasses so quickly
and they they just put 'em in the sink.
I mean they don't even put them in the,
we haven't even gotten our kids
to put things in the dishwasher
unless we're there and
tell them to do it, right?
But they'll be like,
oh look, there's 12 glasses.
We could have guests.
And then like the next
morning, I'll be like,
where's a freaking glass?
- No glasses.
And they're all in the
sink upside down dirty
when the dishwasher's empty, right?
- But what I do,
because first of all, I like to,
I'm just like I'm not going
to contribute to the mayhem.
So what I do nine times out of 10,
if I use a glass in the kitchen,
take the glass, I drink some water.
I immediately wash the glass
and put it back on the counter,
put it back on the shelf.
- That's great.
- Nine times out of 10.
- Wow.
- Now the additional one time out of 10,
especially if it's like a Saturday
and I'm like I'm gonna come back here,
I'll drink it and then I'll
put my glass on the counter
at a certain place like behind the sink
because I'm like my kids are not gonna,
they're not gonna do this.
- No one's gonna grab,
so it's your secret spot
where you know you can go back to it.
- So I will do this.
- Yeah, I have a secret spot.
I mean, I carry around a
water bottle in my own house.
- So you don't need this.
You don't need glasses.
- And then we drink a
lot of cans to a fault.
But I think there's an
answer here in everybody,
I think there should be a rack,
kind of like when I was talking
about the pill box for
every day of the week,
I think there needs to be a drying rack
that has a spot for
each person's cup to be,
after they use it to rinse it
and then put it upside
down on a drying rack
that's compact enough
to be hidden somewhere
'cause this is ugly,
you don't want this out on the counter.
You want to have behind a cabinet.
You just want to have, this is my glass.
Every person only has one glass
and then that's the
only glass they can use
and they always know where it is
and they're in charge of it.
Glasses aren't communal anymore.
And there should be a drying rack.
- I hate to break it to you.
I've tried a version of this three times
and I was the instigator of it
and I was the only enforcer of it.
We didn't do exactly
what you just described.
But I told Jessie, I said,
"These boys use so many glasses.
We need to get glasses that
either have their names on them
or have like a design on them
and it's like this is your glass".
- Or their picture if they
don't know their name.
You don't want them to have any excuses.
"Don't remember my name."
- It doesn't work.
It doesn't work because what do they do?
They use the glass that
has their name on it
and they put it in the sink
and then when they want
something else to drink,
they go to another glass.
You cannot get them to cooperate.
They are impervious to systems.
- They have not experienced
enough of the consequences
of not completing the cycle of a glass.
If they washed and put
away all the glasses,
if they cared about that somehow
or were held accountable to it,
you know, when there's stuff in the sink,
I call 'em back,
I bring 'em back in there and I say,
"Put this in the dishwasher.
You made this mac and cheese
at three o'clock in the afternoon
or three o'clock in the morning
and you left it all here.
I need you to move this into here.
I need you to complete your task."
It doesn't work.
It is hopeless.
- You kind of have a
choice to make as a parent.
Am I gonna bring them
back into the kitchen
to try to teach them a life lesson
or am I gonna just try to keep them alive
until they go to college
and then they'll figure
that shit out on their own?
That's kind of where I'm at.
But I will say,
sometimes I even go into the whole like
typical dad rant where I'm like,
"Do you have any idea
how many children there are in the world
that if I were to bring them
a glass with their name on it
like it would be like the
best day of their year?"
You know what I'm saying?
Like the whole things that
our parents used to do to us
about where the kids starving and stuff.
And I'm like, "This is a privilege.
We went through the trouble
to go to this website
to get this cup with your name on it.
And this would be a treat to
so many children out there,
but you're just taking it
and treating it like any other glass."
- It's a personalized glass
and you need to get with the program.
- Yeah and that doesn't
work either, by the way.
If you're a young parent
and you want to go on one of the rants
where you compare your children's plight
with the plight of other
children in the world,
it doesn't work.
- Nope.
- It doesn't mean you
won't try it many times,
but it does not work.
- So Ashley you're right.
It is okay to leave your
glass on the counter
with the intention to use it again later.
- She did not say what her position was.
- No, she didn't say.
- She just said a family who disagrees.
- You're in charge of the
complete cycle of the glass
and you can leave it out
as long as you ultimately
are the one to put it away
at the end of the day.
- What I want to say
is that you all have to agree on a system,
but if my family is any guide for this,
they will not agree on a system
and this is an intractable problem
that will cause strife in
your family for many years.
- Just remove all glasses.
Andrew Conn tweeted at us.
"Nesquick powder or chocolate syrup?"
And there were a bunch
of food related conflicts
and I realized we could get in on these,
but there's a whole other podcast
produced at Mythical called
"A Hot Dog is a Sandwich"
where mythical chef Josh and Nicole,
every Wednesday, they get
it into a food debate.
- Right and they actually know
what they're talking about.
- You know, tacos versus burritos,
crunchy peanut versus smooth.
- I mean the name of the podcast
"A Hotdog is a Sandwich'
is based on a very famous
food debate in itself.
- So we're gonna resist the temptation
to infringe on their territory
'cause I love what
they're doing over there.
If you haven't checked it out,
definitely check it out.
Start with the most recent one,
work your way backwards.
- I agree with that.
Can I suggest what I
would call a third way.
You know, sometimes
there's two conflicting-
- Nesquik powder, chocolate syrup or what?
- And there's a third way
that I'm gonna propose.
And that is actual chocolate.
And here's why I'm gonna say this.
- I thought you were just gonna say,
you could just buy chocolate milk,
which is great by the way.
Boy that's a treat I haven't had in years.
- My favorite hot chocolate.
- Actual chocolate?
- Okay and I'm about to,
well I don't know,
You've got weird opinions about food.
- 'Cause I do have an answer
and I think it's one of these two.
- The best hot chocolate
that I've ever had
hands down is Mike McKarg's wife, Jenny,
will do this hot chocolate
in a crock pot, right,
and it's just-
- It's milky.
- It's so great.
And it has made me not like
any other hot chocolate.
And she briefly described
to me what was in it.
I didn't listen that intently.
But the one thing I did hear was-
- You didn't want to make it,
you just wanted to drink it.
- Yeah the one thing I did hear
is that it's got actual chocolate,
I think actual chocolate chips in it.
So it literally is composed
of melted chocolate
and other ingredients, including milk.
I don't think any water sees this thing.
I think it's milk.
Anyway, so I think the third
way is actual chocolate
and it is the best way.
That doesn't answer this question.
- That's hot chocolate, Rhett.
They're talking about chocolate
milk, not hot chocolate.
- That's true.
- None of that matters.
Yeah, I was thinking of
a different beverage.
But you can make hot
chocolate with these things.
- It just goes to show you
what heat can do to a beverage,
make it something totally different.
So yeah the third option
is just buying actual chocolate milk.
There was this cheap,
carton of chocolate milk
that my mom used to buy
and it was so thick as a kid,
oh, I miss it so much.
It was like Borden brand.
- Well you know the ones,
the ones in the glass bottle-
- The ones in the glass
are really good now.
- Like one time-
- It looks like the milkman
would drop it off, yeah.
- We were hanging out with Julian Smith.
And he was like, "Guys,
you gotta have this."
Was that?
- It was eggnog but it
was the same company.
- It was from this farm,
like the so-and-so farm.
And they do a really good hot chocolate.
- Last night I went Link Neal old school.
Of course in high school and in college,
every night I would have a
spoonful of peanut butter
and then I would take the Hershey's syrup,
the chocolate syrup here,
Andrew, and I would,
you know, I'd pour it in and I would
dingety dingety ding ding, mix it up.
But back,
and I did that last night.
Oh it was great.
- Ironic.
- I love eating-
- Is that why you chose this question
because you did it last night?
- It's fresh on my mind.
But as a middle schooler
and grade schooler,
at my Nana's house, she
had the Nesquik powder
and I would eat that every day,
huge glass of that.
- You'd eat it?
- Yeah, I eat my chocolate
milk with a spoon.
- Weird.
- I don't drink it.
I eat the peanut butter off the spoon
and then I use the spoon to dip-
- Don't describe it.
It just is gonna annoy me.
- And that's how I eat my smoothie now
as a middle aged man.
Every morning,
I eat my smoothie with a spoon
because of this nostalgia.
I got to say, I think Nesquik powder
is my official answer.
- Interesting.
- Even though we have
Hershey's syrup at the house,
it tells you to keep
it in the refrigerator
which drives me nuts.
- Is this because of taste?
Because clearly something that's a syrup
is easier to mix than
something that's a powder.
- It's not easier to mix
if your syrup is not room temp or warm.
If it's refrigerated and
cold, it's harder to mix.
It still works,
but it doesn't mix as readily as powder,
but it tastes different.
It's a different taste.
It's probably a more
manufactured synthetic taste.
I'm talking about the powder here,
but I have a nostalgic affinity to that.
It's closely related to my
Kraft American sliced cheese
nostalgic affinity.
I opened my refrigerator two days ago
and there was a stack, like that whole,
I hadn't seen this in years.
We have not had individually packaged
sliced Kraft American
cheese in our fridge,
I mean over 10 years,
it's just not something we have.
- Right yeah my wife doesn't do it either.
- I knew it had to do,
I didn't even ask,
Lily went to the grocery
store and bought it
and I know it has something
to do with TikTok.
I didn't even ask.
- Oh, it's probably 'cause
you throw it on people,
like you throw it on people's foreheads
and throw it on babies and stuff.
- No, she was gonna put it on top
of another type of mac
and cheese that she's-
- But you know what I'm talking about
where you take a slice of American cheese
and you throw it on a stranger?
- Yeah that's funny,
but that's not why she was doing it.
I tasted a piece and boy it's-
- It's good.
- It's good but it's not cheese anymore.
- Speaking of Josh on
this, mythical chef Josh,
has very strong opinions
about American cheese
and I agree with him.
He's not a food snob at all.
And you know what Lily's
talking about using it for?
Putting it on top of mac and cheese, phew.
Which by the way-
- She didn't like it by the by the way.
She did not like it.
- She didn't like it the way she used it?
- She didn't like the taste,
she didn't like the experience.
We got Lincoln to try a piece
and he didn't seem like he liked it.
- 'Cause recently I
smoked that pork shoulder
and had you guys over for it
and Lily brought the mac and cheese
and I thought that mac and
cheese was really good.
But you're saying it didn't
have the slices on it?
- No, she was making a
cup of mac and cheese,
like the instant cup of mac and cheese
and then I think draping a
slice over the top of that
as if it needed more cheese.
- It always needs more cheese.
- All right, so are you going
with syrup or powder on this?
- I don't have a strong opinion.
I'm going with,
I interpret this as hot chocolate
and I'll go with real chocolate.
- All right, solved that one.
From Paridhi, mythicanoi,
"How to pronounce pigeons.
I say it's pi-gen
but my girlfriend thinks it's pee-geeans.
We Googled it and I think
it says pi-gens only
but she insists that they are wrong."
- Pee-geeans, pee-geeans.
- I'm gonna say,
what I'm going with here
is I'm gonna just remove the pee part
and I think this is a common
mistake that people make
when there is an EO or IO in a word.
So you think that,
it looks like there's two syllables
in the second half of pigeon.
I think that's what's up for debate here.
- Pee-geean, pee-geean,
that's what she's saying.
- Does pigeon, is pigeon like a shortening
of the actual word?
- Pee-geean.
- When you look at this,
you see right here,
it's very clearly a two
syllable word, pigeon, pigeon,
pigeon is the correct pronunciation.
- P-i-j- upside down
e-n, in the dictionary.
- I think I may have at some point,
whether it's Good Mythical
More or this podcast,
I may have already
relayed this information,
but my son Shepherd
had this pigeon thing
that happened last year.
And I don't mean like an
incident with a pigeon.
What I mean is that-
- I vaguely remember this.
- He started at a new school, right?
And at some point he
communicated to the class
and to his teacher that he liked pigeons.
Now let me be clear,
we didn't know that he liked pigeons.
He had never talked about
pigeons before to us.
I'm not saying he didn't like pigeons.
Just saying it didn't seem
like it was really that big of a thing.
- It's not something you have to declare.
"Family, meeting please.
I got something I need to tell you all."
- He went out on this pigeon limb
and I think he saw
that pigeons could kind of be his thing
and that he was getting a response
from his classmates and his teachers.
And they were like this is kind of funny
that this kid's into pigeons.
Like he drew,
they had this one thing
where you drew yourself as an animal
and he drew himself as a pigeon.
- Oh, I remember this.
- It was beautiful.
And then the theme of
the entire year last year
or their school year,
and I'm talking like the 2019/2020,
so we're talking like fall
2019 was micronations right?
And so the whole idea was
that you were gonna get
into a group with some other students
and you were gonna create a fake
sort of a fictional nation.
And as you learn about
like the way economies work
and the way resources work in a nation,
you're going to sort of create a story
around a fake nation
and present it to the rest of the class
as a way of embodying
these real things that exist in the world,
but doing it in a fun,
fictitious way, right?
- Which we did with Cheeseastan.
- Exactly.
So interestingly,
there was another person
in Shepherd's group
that also had strong opinions.
And it became a little bit
of a point of contention
when Shepherd suggested
that the name of their
micronation be called Poloma,
which is pigeon in Spanish.
(laughing)
- Good name.
- And the thing that was true about Poloma
was the fact that it is
just a nation of pigeons.
Long story short,
Shepherd won this argument
and Poloma ended up being
a nation of pigeons.
And it kind of became,
again, I ended up asking
Shepherd about this
and I was like,
"Shepherd, explain the
explain the pigeon thing to me
and like how it happened."
And he was like, 'cause I was like,
"I don't remember you saying
that you really liked
pigeons before this."
And he was like, "Well,
to be honest with you,
it's not that I don't like pigeons,
but I said that I liked pigeons
and everyone started reacting to it
so I just kind of leaned into it."
So much so that this past year
when he started the new school year
and of course this new school year,
was very different for the kids
because they weren't in it for
very long because of COVID.
His teacher,
we had like a Zoom
conference with his teacher
and she was like,
"You know, we love it when Shepherd,
he doesn't always participate,
but when he does participate,
we love it when he participates
and he's funny and he tells funny stories.
And also I would love to talk to him
about his love for pigeons."
And then she holds up a mug
that says something
about pigeons on the mug.
And I'm like, did this woman get this mug
or does she just have
an affinity for pigeons?
But like now that he has made
this pigeon sort of thing about himself,
it's part of him now.
- It's his brand.
- You have to kind of keep carrying it on.
So I wasn't gonna break it to her
that the pigeon thing was just something
he kind of pulled out of his
butt and then leaned into.
- But she loves pigeons.
She's legit.
- She wanted to connect
with him about pigeons.
And I was like, "Yeah, he'll love that.
I don't know what I said."
- Like pranking the teacher.
- Well, it's not much of
a prank because I mean.
- It's my kind of prank.
- It's a very long play prank.
Like again, it's not,
I think he's actually
gotten more into pigeons
as a result of this.
- Self-fulfilling prophecy, yeah.
- But I can just say,
it's fair to say he kind of
got carried away, you know?
That was like trying to
be a carrier pigeon pond
but it was a little weak.
- As a father of a
self-described pigeon lover,
I can say pigeon is the
correct pronunciation.
It's not pee-gean.
- Pee-gean.
Paloma is a place in California.
- Oh, we can go visit.
How far away is it?
- It is just southeast
of Sacramento, California
right in the middle of the state.
- I was watching the "Family
Feud" the other day which I,
I love watching it.
And the question was,
"Name a city" or like,
it was like, "Name a city
that you would like to
go on vacation to."
Anywhere in the world, right?
- Okay.
- And it was like,
okay so number one answer was?
- Hawaii.
(laughing)
Interestingly, one of the
guys said the Caribbean
which is also not a city.
- I should be on "Family Feud", huh?
- Yeah, you would be a great contestant.
You're a YouTube highlight
waiting to happen.
Listen, I want to be on "Family Feud".
I seriously want to be on "Family Feud".
- Cities (laughing)
- Titties or cities?
You gotta be clear.
- They're both tough.
I mean it's like once you say those words,
it's like I get bumfungled.
What's a city and what's a titty?
- What do you think's
the number one answer.
- Greece, Athens.
- Eh, you've got
two X's.
- What is
the number one answer?
- Paris.
- Oh Paris, that's a city.
- You know like Paris, London.
- I've been there, to London.
- Rome.
- Oh, Rome, not Athens.
- New York City.
- Okay.
- So you know those kinds of cities.
But like-
- Los Angeles.
- They were,
I don't think Los Angeles
was on there actually.
Oh, maybe it was.
- Paloma.
- But it got down to this
family had two strikes
and like Steve Harvey's asking this woman,
it's like, "Okay, the other family's
gonna have an opportunity to steal
if you don't get this.
Name a city that people
would like to vacation in."
And she's like, "Sacramento."
- Sacramento?
And it's just like, okay.
- What did he say?
- But Steve didn't,
he didn't have as much fun.
He just was like, "Sacramento".
- Okay.
- Sacramento.
He made a,
of course it wasn't up there.
But he made the choice to not lean in
and make fun of her too much
like he does a lot.
- Well yeah, it's not a four hour show.
if he did that for every dumb answer,
then what would happen?
Ryker tweeted at us,
"I want to get a motorcycle.
My wife thinks it's too unsafe.
I work in a funeral home.
Trust me, people die every
day from all manner of things.
Mortality is a bitch."
Oh God, this took an aggressive turn.
"What should I do,
stay in bed wearing a helmet?
I want to be alive, not just live."
Wow, hmm, Ryker, Ryker with a Y.
I mean that's,
the name really seems,
it adds up with motorcyclist.
You know, if you've got
a Y in your first name,
I think you're much more
likely to be a motorcyclist.
- I agree with that.
- I think you're living on the edge.
I think you're willing to take more risk.
Because there are more risks.
And this is a real
conversation that happens a lot
with people wanting
that motorcycle.
- A lot.
- Well I have an-
- I've got two front,
go ahead, I didn't mean to cut you off.
- An analogy here
- Go ahead.
- Because I don't want
to ride a motorcycle.
I don't want to own a motorcycle.
I'm too sensitive to like falling down,
not just dying,
but I know that most people
who own motorcycles are like,
"How many times have you
laid this thing down?"
Like it happens.
It ends up happening.
You don't always die,
but like I'm just in a
place in my life right now
where those kinds of
inconveniencing injuries,
let alone death,
it's not something I want to entertain.
But what I've said for years
is that I've been very
interested in ultralight flying,
right, we've talked about this before
And then there's many times
where I've thought to myself,
like I should get my pilot's license.
I should fly a little plane, right?
Any time I bring this up with my wife,
she's like, "No."
Now she was in a plane crash.
- That makes a difference.
She was too young to remember
it but it did happen.
- When she was less than one year old,
her parents were in a small plane
that clipped a power line and crashed.
And no one was no one
was seriously injured.
But anyway, it's like this sort of,
there's a sort of this lore in her family.
And first of all,
how often do you hear about
somebody dying in a small plane?
It seems like it's pretty often, right?
And so I've kind of dropped this.
I've kind of been like,
"All right, I'm not gonna push this."
But for me, the only way too,
'cause I know that it is more dangerous,
like me not getting a pilot's license,
me not ultra light flying
is a safer long-term life choice
than me deciding to do it, right?
But we don't,
like Ryker said,
we don't just avoid all risk, right?
What do I do, stay in
bed wearing a helmet?
- He wants to be alive, not just live.
- So to me, this is an individual,
and I'm being serious about this.
I'm not trying to make a joke about this.
This is a thing that lots
of people argue about.
And it isn't just always
well the husband wants
to do something dangerous
and the wife wants to keep him from it.
That happens a lot of times.
But I'm just saying in any relationship
there might be something
that you want to do
that there is inherent risk in it.
And we know that it is risky
or significantly riskier
to ride a motorcycle than to be in a car,
27 times as likely to
die in a motorcycle crash
than a car crash, right?
- Because for obvious reasons
you're riding on top of the vehicle,
you're not inside the vehicle.
And that's according
to the National Highway Traffic
and Safety Administration.
- Oh, we're familiar with them.
We've made videos for them.
- Yeah, 27 times more likely to die.
- So, but how do you evaluate this, right?
Because-
- Than in a car.
- What if Ryker's number
one passion in life
is to ride a motorcycle.
Now, if this is something
that developed after they got married,
and you know what,
you have to take into account
the fact that your wife
doesn't want you to do this.
Now, if you were like a motorcycle guy,
it's a part of your identity,
you're super into it
before you got married,
when you get into a relationship,
I feel like that's a
different conversation.
Because it's like you married this person,
you got into this relationship
knowing that this is a passion of theirs,
you're gonna have to live with that risk.
- That's a complicating factor.
It does change the complexity
of the conversation.
- But let's just assume
that this is happening
after the relationship.
- But I don't even know that
you have to be prepared.
I still think it's probably a decision
for the two of you but, you know.
- Yeah, you still got
to come to a decision,
but it is different if it
was a preexisting condition,
motorcycle love.
- We know two people, Mike and Nick,
who had motorcycles and then,
well Mike was in more of an
accident than I think Nick was,
but like when Nick
started having children,
it was like there was a negotiation
or discussions that led to him
getting rid of his motorcyle.
- Right.
I mean there's a lot
of technique and skill
and it's a demanding hobby.
To be really good at it
and to be defensive in your driving
and to be aware of everything
because it's like there's
so much constant risk.
And there's certainly parameters,
I don't know what they are,
but I would think there are parameters
that would make it more safe.
Like, I'm kind of guessing here
so I'm talking out of school,
but when you're motorcyclists
traveling in groups,
it's like if you've got a buddy,
you're more likely to.
I mean there are things you
can do to mitigate your risk.
I think that might be one of 'em.
You know you're more visible in a group.
- You mean wear an orange shirt,
wear a bright helmet?
- I'm saying join a motorcycle gang.
- Okay, well okay.
- Yean and probably wear
like really bright colors.
Dress like a clown.
- The approach to the motorcycling,
like if you're a motorcycle stunt person,
if you're like,
well I'm gonna be a TikToker,
an Instagram motorcycle person
and I'm gonna do like wheelies
down the middle of the interstate
without a helmet in a bikini,
then that's problematic
on a number of levels.
I agree with that.
But I feel like the factors are-
- If you really,
I guess what I'm getting at
is if you really care about it,
if I'm Ryker,
I might do a bunch of research
to then bring that stat
of 27 times more likely
to die than in a car,
I might can bring that
stat down with classes,
there's certain stipulations.
- Okay, you can minimize your risk,
but you're still gonna be-
I think that,
I'm trying to use the motorcycle thing
as something that represents
anything that a partner wants
to do that's higher risk,
whether it's small planes or anything.
- Even me for mountain biking,
like I've come home a few times
and we've gone off on new
trails and I did tell Christie
and I was like,
"I don't know why I'm telling her this."
But I said, "You know, I was on this trail
that if I would have fallen
off my bike the wrong way
I think I would have died."
- That's not a good
thing to tell your wife.
- "And I don't think I'm
gonna go on that trail again."
And I'm pretty cautious, you know?
So like when I get to those places,
like sometimes I'll walk my bike.
So I'm increasingly more risk averse.
But it is a risky thing
on some of these single tracks.
- So let's assume
just so we kind of arrive at
some conclusion for Ryker,
that this is a passion
that developed after the
relationship started.
So we're doing away from that one factor.
And let's assume that if
Ryker decides to do this,
he's going to do it
in as safe as a way as he can.
He's gonna be a safe and
responsible motorcyclist.
Still riskier than not
deciding to be a motorcyclist
and to ride in a car, right?
To me, the factors at play are,
I think he has a point in terms of,
"Well, this is something I want to do
and I recognize that it's risky
and I'm gonna die at some point."
Okay there's a point there.
But I think that,
it's like how resistant
is your wife to this
and then how passionate are you about,
is this like you've determined
that this is something
that you have to have
in order to live a full life?
'Cause I do believe there
might be some people
who would say that.
It's like if I don't get to go skydiving,
if I don't get to do this thing,
if I don't get to be a rock climber,
then I'm not fulfilling my passion.
And I think that this is a,
every couple has to answer this.
Because it might get to a
point where it's just like,
this is a risky thing, you might die,
but I can tell that
you're committed to this.
Again, it might be the kind of thing,
like this whole ultra light flying thing,
when my kids finally
leave, are on their own
and I really have a midlife crisis,
not just a little bit of one
like I've been having,
but like a real one and I'm like,
"Baby, either I get a convertible
or I start flying planes."
It's one or the other.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, I think at some point-
- Could get both.
- Depending on your life stage,
how old are you?
You still got kids who are
dependent on you as a father?
I think there's a lot of different factors
that go into this.
I just don't think there's
a straight answer to this.
- Yeah, but I think if
you really care about it,
it's a negotiation.
And you might have to go so far as to say,
"Well okay if the worst happens,
have I really looked at the
risk and taken it into account?"
Meaning I'm getting a
life insurance policy,
and by the way, you have to tell them
that you got a motorcycle
and they're gonna charge
you that much more.
So like there's this kind
of this arbitration thing
that's like if you're not willing to do
what it takes to take care of your family
to accommodate for that risk,
then maybe you're not as committed
as you need to be to do it.
- 'Cause you say if I am
in a motorcycle crash,
you'll get rich.
How's that sound?
- Well I'm gonna take care,
I'm gonna take out a policy
that's gonna make sure
you're taken care of
so I'm not just like
leaving you in a lurch
because I had to not
just live but be alive.
It's a negotiation, so.
- Regardless of your intentions
and regardless of how safe you are-
- How much are you willing
to sacrifice for the risk?
- Regardless of all the
insurance that you have in place,
if your partner still says,
"I'm not comfortable with this",
I think part of being in a
relationship is to be like,
"Okay I'm gonna give up on this."
You can find something.
Hey, what about one of
those three wheeled bikes?
Just start adding wheels
and see if it helps-
- A spider?
- Yeah.
You're adding a wheel and
a lot of embarrassment.
- That's what the spider
market is all about.
You just unlocked it in my mind.
It's men who wanted a motorcycle
whose wives were not comfortable with it.
- Yeah.
- So they got one of those three wheelers.
That's what it is.
- Yeah and then you know what?
Maybe you need a fourth wheel.
I don't know.
- Then you've just got a car.
- Well, that's your problem.
- You're going in the wrong direction.
Once you get to three wheels,
then you negotiate down to two.
Oh you're talking about
like a literal three wheel motorcycle.
I'm talking about those spiders that have-
- No, I'm talking about the spider,
yeah, I'm talking about that.
- Because there's a three
wheel motorcycle too
that has two wheels in the back,
which I think those are more dangerous
than a regular motorcycle.
- Well, you got to get
your facts straight.
This is not my negotiation.
I mean, but is this the
type of thing that like,
I mean if we're not willing
to go in this business,
but there's somebody out there
who can be more of an arbitration expert
for decisions like this.
Like I wonder if there's someone
on the premises of the
motorcycle dealership
that steps in for arbitration in couples
to help sell the bike.
- No.
- There's a lot of psychology there.
I'd like to talk to a motorcycle salesman.
- The motorcycle salesmen
is only equipping the person
trying to buy the motorcycle
with arguments to then go
home and tell your wife.
That's it exclusively.
- So Ryker, you might want to do that too.
Go to your local dealer
and say, "Hey listen,
you got to give me a pamphlet."
- They probably have a pamphlet.
If you want to sell something
to a motorcycle salesman,
it's a pamphlet that they just give
to people who want to buy motorcycles.
- Hey, be safe out there, Ryker.
- Yeah whatever you decide,
wear an orange helmet.
OpossumQueen, "At work, I drive a truck
that is shared between shifts.
I am one of the shorter people
and a lot of people complain
about my seat position
when they drive after me.
Should we be adjusting our
seat for the next person
or just adjust it for yourself
at the beginning of the shift?"
Okay, I mean as a six seven man
with a five foot three wife
who share a car,
this is a very relevant question to us.
- Now you got a fancier car.
So how does it actually work in your car?
- She's number one and I'm number two.
- Yeah.
- So if you hit number
one, it becomes Jessie's
everything goes to her position.
- But where is it when you get in?
- It's wherever it was the
last time somebody got out.
- Really?
Well then, okay, you're not quite as fancy
as you need to be.
This isn't a competition,
but my car, here's what it does,
when I turn off the car
and then I open the door,
the seat goes all the way back.
So no matter who you are
or how short or tall
or how forward it was,
it goes all the way back
and then it's easy for
everybody to get out.
And then the next person to
get in, it's all the way back
and then it goes forward to that position.
Yes, is that what it does?
- I think technically if
I really wanted to do this
is that my key and her key
tell the car who's getting in the car.
But we lost one of the keys
because we're the McLaughlin's.
- Oh that's advanced.
- So there's just one key
to the car and it's hers.
I'm not talking about
what my my daily driver,
I'm talking about like the
family car that she drives
but I drive occasionally.
Because it's just the button-
- But if it's in her position,
you can't even get in.
- I would break a femur trying to get in.
- I drove Lily's car,
the old Scion,
I had to drive it in
'cause I forgot to charge my car.
And if Lily drove right before me,
she sits so much closer.
Yeah, I can't get in.
Lincoln can't get in the driver's seat.
- But it's so obvious
when I open the door.
It's not like I would
ever make the mistake
of trying to get in.
It's almost like I couldn't,
if you told me for
$100,000, sit in this sit,
I couldn't do it.
It could be like a challenge on "Survivor"
and I would lose.
So I immediately can tell
that this is not made for me.
And so I just hit the number two and wait.
- Even when the car's
not on it still works.
- Yeah.
- Huh.
So I wonder if a OpossumQueen's truck,
it seems like-
- I'm assuming this is not
an automatic situation.
- Queen, you need to move that seat back.
Listen, if you're one
of the shorter people
and you're receiving
complaints about seat position,
hey, I think you should
move your seat back.
And I think it would also make it,
it's not difficult for you to get out,
but it would make it that much easier.
So it's like a win-win.
You slam the seat all the way back,
you have even more room to
just dash out of that thing
and you're being considerate
to the next person,
your coworker.
- You're saying that this is something
that only applies to the short people.
Because what you're saying,
it's a little discriminatory
because the tall people,
they just get in and get out
and they don't have to do anything.
Because you're saying
that everyone from short
to tall is accommodated
in the getting in and
out of the car process
if the seat is back.
- Yeah.
- And then if you're a short person,
you bring it up while driving
and then you take it down.
- I think the shorter people have to defer
to the taller people in this one,
especially in a work environment.
I mean if this is just your family car,
you know, screw 'em.
You know, they don't put
their cups away anyway
so don't put your seat back,
give 'em a little jab.
But this is an easy way
for you to not get demerits on the job.
- I don't know if I,
I understand the logic
of what you're saying
and I understand why it doesn't
apply to the tall people
because it's not like the
tall person can be like,
"You know what a short person
might get into this car after me.
I'm gonna put the seat
up before I get out."
First of all, it's impossible
to put the seat up before before
you get out if you're tall.
You have to get out of the truck
and then like manipulate
the seat from the ground.
So the short person does have the ability
to move the seat up and back.
I do think just because
of the way physics work,
the short people are gonna
get the short end of the stick
in this situation.
- 'Cause when I tried
to get in Lily's car,
I did notice that I would sit in
and then reach down and
adjust the seat back.
But it's like very difficult
for me to get in the car.
- Some of the most uncomfortable
moments of your life.
- But I did that instead
of bending all the way over
to reach under the seat and push it back
'cause then you got like a back injury.
- Yeah, you don't want that.
- Again, it's like you got to calculate
our risk in everything at our age.
OpossumQueen, take one for the team.
Sorry girl.
- I think there's one more
that I don't even think
requires any discussion.
We can just softball, set it
up, knock it out of the park
- Hit me.
- From rebelliousmary.
"My boyfriend thinks the
blinds closes slats down
when they clearly should
be closed slats up.
The light comes through still
when he closes them down.
That's not enough evidence for him.
He thinks closing them
down will prevent peepers.
What do y'all think?
- I'm with her.
- Mary you're right.
I mean this is so-
- Blinds go up.
Peepers still can't see in
and it blocks the light
from shining through that
little slit onto the floor.
- Well, case in point.
Just yesterday, I'm on a Zoom call
and I'm facing a window.
My office in the creative
house, faces a window.
And I don't know if it
was me or somebody else
had closed the close them
slats down and it was sunny
and there were these lines
all over my desk and my face.
And so I immediately turned them slats up
and it was this nice even light.
And no, you can't see through it.
- Is there any advantage to slats down?
It looks nicer.
It looks smoother-
- To be down?
- For them to be down.
That's the only thing I can
come up with why it's like,
it seems like it's,
it seems like that's
the right way to do it
'cause it makes it smooth.
It's like scales on the back of a snake.
It's kind of like rubbing
a cat the wrong direction
when you turn those blinds up
it's a little unsettling to me.
- You've complicated it now.
- But I believe that
it's right functionally.
Functionally, I cannot
think of any other reason
to have 'em go the other way
except for the scales of a snake.
- Well, all I'mg gonna say
is your boyfriend's stated reason
is he thinks that this
will prevent peepers
and it's just not, it's not true.
They can't see through either way.
- You can't prevent peepers.
Peepers gonna peep.
- Yeah, the peeper's
still outside the window
regardless of how you've got the blinds.
- We should give a heads up.
We're releasing a special
episode of Ear Biscuits
this coming Thursday.
If you're listening to
this one fresh on Monday,
then just a few days later,
we got a special extra,
I'mm a call it a mini episode.
I don't think it's gonna be
as long as a typical one.
It's part of the Dell Podference.
So we're gonna be talking
about how we weathered COVID
from a business standpoint.
So don't be alarmed when there's
an entirely extra mini Ear
Biscuit later this week.
Just want to give you that heads up.
- And then I'll close with a rec here.
I'm choosing this rec
because I believe that it is,
it could be a point of contention.
And that is if you are,
just I'll start with,
if you are a blue cheese lover
or you are blue cheese tolerant,
some people don't like
the taste of blue cheese,
this is not gonna be helpful for you.
- Okay, I'm checking out then.
- Go online, find the recipe
for blue cheese close slaw.
There's one on Food Network that's good.
My wife when I was
talking earlier about the,
having you guys over for
the pork shoulder that I,
I smoked this pork shoulder
for 17 hours, okay?
It was like 23 pounds.
- I ate it over the
course of like 14 minutes.
- My wife was like
of course we got to
make slaw for this thing
'cause we're doing it
North Carolina style.
And she was like, "What do you think
if I made a blue cheese slaw?"
I was like, "First of
all, I love this idea.
Second of all, you can't
just make a blue cheese slaw,
you have to make a regular slaw
for people who don't like blue cheese.
But I love this idea" and she made it
and for me as a blue cheese lover,
it was revolutionary.
It has changed the way I think about slaw.
I was not a slaw person.
I put slaw on my barbecue
almost out of obligation
because I'm from North Carolina
to be honest with you.
It isn't like I like it.
It's kind of like, yeah,
this is what you do.
Try the blue cheese slaw.
And again, if you're a blue cheese lover
or if you're just blue cheese tolerant,
if you're the kind of person
that if there's blue cheese in something,
it throws everything off for you,
don't try it, you're not gonna like it.
But I'm just gonna tell you right now,
try it before you knock it.
- My likey.
- Blue cheese slaw.
- Okay, #earbiscuits.
Again, we'll see you for
a special one on Thursday
and then a normal one
like every other Monday.
(upbeat music)
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] to watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to
click on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(upbeat music)